hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
today I'm testing something out because
I don't know what's gonna happen I
haven't tried this I've yet to have all
of my did I do something thing wait okay
no I think I might have touched them by
accident I've yet to have all of my home
pods in one room next to each other
where they can hear me fairly equally so
what I'm wondering is if I say hey which
one's gonna answer me are they all gonna
play is just one gonna play what
determines who's gonna respond to my
voice because I'm not really sure this
is the one that I've been keeping in my
office I think this is the one that I
have downstairs in my kitchen this one I
think is in my bedroom and this one I
also have downstairs in another room so
these are my babies these are my
children yes I know I have a problem
I've already addressed it with myself
with you guys but at least the issue has
been addressed and that means maybe I'm
one step closer to you know not being in
Apple attic anymore but for the time
being I am leave me alone I'll do what I
want I'll do it I want my body I'll do
it I want my money and this is what I
choose to do with it but the sake of not
triggering any of your smart devices I'm
gonna be bleeping out to the word so I
won't trigger any of you guys watching
this video so as you can see here all
four of the home pods are there at the
bottom we've got the game room Hope pod
my office home pod my room home pod and
the upstairs home pod it's time for the
test
who's gonna answer first hey play me
some music okay I'll start with the
writer by Ellie Goulding okay so this
one answered me hey play me some music
let's get going with some Katy Perry
okay now she's still playing so what if
I play all four of them right they're
all playing something different now
play me some Slayer here's Slayer if I
maybe if I move over here play me some
Backstreet Boys sure here's a
personalized station of Backstreet Boys
hey play me some Bette Midler you know
she's a personalized station of Bette
Midler hmm well this experiment is not
as exciting as I thought it was gonna be
how can I get them all to play the same
thing at the same time because without
the latest iOS release okay so here we
have our song and if I hit play I can
decide where I want to go so I can play
it in the game room my office
[Music]
here's my office 1 and playing right
here my room this one and the upstairs
is over here today using airplay I'm
able to decide which one I want to play
too
but unfortunately without the software
update that hopefully will be coming
very very soon I want to be able to play
the same song on all of these devices at
the same time that will be a release in
the future iOS update but right now it
is it's not a thing and it's so
upsetting because I really want to have
these set as stereo speakers on my TV
and much like so knows I'm able to play
the same song throughout the entire
house on all of them but I can't do that
here I wonder if I hit play on all of
them play echosmith cool kids why did
you decide to pick it up there's cool
kids by echosmith play cool kids by
echosmith no no she's playing new kids
by echosmith
it's a great song ok so what do I do now
basically my test is over if you have 4
home pods plus your phone only one of
them is gonna decide to answer you I was
really hoping this would get crazy and
all four of them would answer and things
we get silly do you want to be my best
friend that's nice
I'd like to be your friend well which
one so you want to be my friend
well I guess since I'm here I'll give
you an update on how I'm loving my home
pipes it's so far and honestly I know
that there has been a lot of backlash
but there's also been a lot of people
who really really loved them and I yes
I'm one of the people who really really
love my home pod home pods we're like
family these are my best friends I feel
like it's been a big toss-up between
people who love the home pod of people
that don't like the home pod and
honestly I think it's absolutely great
for what I do and what I need it for it
is perfect it sounds great in every room
I have home kit completely integrated so
all of my lights are completely
connected to this and when I come home
my lights turn on and when I leave my
lights turn off and I can set specific
timers to do all kinds of different
routines and yes you can do that with
other smart devices too but obviously
this works perfectly with my Apple
ecosystem because if you guys are new
here then you might not know that I'm a
really big apple fan surprise the news
is out but it all seriousness they
really need to get the update rolled out
where we're able to use the surround
sound and be able to use this in all
rooms and be able to play the same song
as I feel like a lot of people maybe
waiting for that update to buy one I
know that was my original recommendation
to just buy one and then if you want to
buy more later then do it when the
update is out but I clearly do not heed
my own warning or my suggestion because
like I said I had a problem anyway I'm
sorry that this wasn't a more
interesting video as hoping it's
something crazy would happen but since
it didn't I thought I would share that
with you anyway in case you're just as
curious as I was to see what would
happen and nothing really happened so
that's that let me know if you guys have
any other suggestions for videos in the
comments below and let me know what you
guys think of the home pot do you have
one do not have one I would love to hear
all of your thoughts and I will see you
guys in the next video bye hey play me
some music I'll start with smoke and
mirrors I imagine dragons good choice I
will make one note though whenever I say
heyse all four of these light up at the
same time now I'm really leaving
[Music]